this is the theme the theme you know
this is the thing is the bismillah al
hamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be with
you thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the dent show we have a very
exciting show with you with my next
guest dr. Lawrence Brown we're going to
be talking about a subject that
sometimes it's kind of heavy for a lot
of people a lot of people might get a
little bit uncomfortable talking about
religion talking about something that's
very important what's the purpose of
life why are you here in this world
where are you going when you die def
it's a scary reality but it's a reality
but you got a lot of weird things
attributed to religion but when you dig
a little deep you see that it has
nothing to do with God people
attributing so many different
superstitions by this fairy dust and you
float in the air by this and you'll be
safe all of these things you see the
preachers and teachers out there
propagating and you know what people are
just sick of it they're sick of being
ripped off they're sick of all the
different things that now you know what
it just doesn't make sense but we're
going to again try to make sense of it
all here on the D show we come back with
dr. Lawrence Brown we'll be right back
this is the thing
this is the this is the this is the
Salaam alaikum peace be with you aleykum
Salaam so I hope ricotta dr. Lawrence
Brown back on the Dean show how are you
feeling pretty good thank you for
finding the time people can go to the
Dean show calm you have your conversion
story and other great shows that we've
done with you you have a PhD in
religious studies you have a DD dr.
divinity you were trying very hard to be
a Christian you used to be an atheist
now you're one who chosen consciously to
surrender and submit to the one god
that's a Muslim defining these words I
feel are very important now you heard me
open the topic religion is very heavy
people don't want to talk about it you
know what many things have been
attributed to the religion you know
people i mentioned fairy dust people are
selling these statues icons you know
these ambulance and making money it's
become a big business preachers and
teachers doing cartwheels it's a big
show show time you know a business and
you know what is corruption and people
are exploiting people and people are fed
up they're sick of it but do we blame
God or do we blame the people truth
being mixed with falsehood people are
fed up what do you got to say about this
doctor Brown I guess to begin with I
would back up because you said people
are sick of talking about religion one
thing I have to say is no actually
people are not sick of talking about
religion people are very happy to talk
about religion as long as you agree with
them as long as they're talking about
you know their brand of religion but but
actually there there are a lot of people
who don't like to even be approached on
the subject they've become so sensitive
they've sort of withdrawn into a bit of
a cocoon and
I think I think those sensitivities to a
certain degree are understandable for
the reasons you just mentioned you know
people are tired of being woken up on on
Sunday morning by somebody knocking on
their door saying you know can you know
can we talk to you about the Bible
they're tired of being approached in
different ways they you know they they
see or have seen with their own eyes how
religion has been manipulated how
charlatans have used religion to to
misguide others to charlatans Charlotte
if he's what do you mean by charlatans
charlatans basically confidence men
Kahneman Kahneman yeah basic basically
people who are using religion as a tool
by which to accomplish their worldly
ends they they act like they're all
pious and righteous while they're
building a you know five million dollar
mansion on the donations of their of
their followers and they you know
they're basically they're basically
ripping people off as you said ripping
people off in the name of God now you
heard me mention fairy dust and you
heard me mention and you just talked
about it manipulation stealing people's
money telling them okay know if you and
you see a lot of this late night you'll
stay up one night and you come home and
you feel something's missing you might
have just come from the nightclub you
might have just come from a breakup and
you sit home and now there's no one
around you got some peace of mind and
you're reflecting because it's a rat
race of life but now you turn on the TV
and there's someone trying to exploit
you they're saying you buy this dust we
put it in an envelope and we'll send it
over to you 4 for 9 99 and all your
prayers will be answered and now they
attribute this to religion and they
tribute this to God these superstitions
and all these other crazy ideas and
gimmicks and people just get fed up what
are you thoughts on this you know what
can we say I mean we all know we all
know about this there are a lot of there
are a lot of you know so-called holy
things in
that are promoted in different religions
whether it's whether it's holy water or
whether it's in actions such as faith
healing or whether it is something being
sold as a sacred amulet or something
that will bring you a good luck or just
selling prayers basically doesn't
selling prayers yes yeah and I think
that you know I think whether we can
just understand that looking from a
historical point of view everybody out
there knows that there have been times
in history when religion has been used
to justify Wars to justify persecution
to justify genocide to justify all kinds
of different atrocities right in the
name of God and and yet deep down we
know that these are not godly things
these things that were done in God's
name were not godly things now you might
find some people saying well yeah the we
have the medieval Inquisition the
Spanish Inquisition that was a righteous
thing to do because they have that mind
point that is in support of their
religious views but I think the vast
majority of people would agree that no
wasn't I mean it wasn't I mean torturing
and killing people just because you were
intolerant of their beliefs is that
something that we see in the example of
Jesus Christ is that something that we
see in the example of Moses Abraham
Ishmael Isaac it's not something that we
see in the example of any of the
prophets so how dare somebody come up
with that and say that they are doing it
in the name of God but so so although
there may be some people who defend it
because because it fits their ideology I
think the vast majority of people agree
that it was it was a it was a crime it
was a sickness it was genocide and it
doesn't matter whether we're talking
about the
you know the Inquisition it doesn't
matter if we're talking about different
religious wars if we're talking about
colonialism if we're talking about
slavery I mean slavery was was founded
upon a religious principle the curse of
ham okay the concept the concept that
one of the sons of Noah was cursed and
in in being cursed his people became
people of color and became a cursed to
servitude and on this on this basis you
know on this on this basis Christians
justified the parasitic slavery that
developed in the history of England and
America they justified como colonialism
where they con alized excuse me where
they where they Colonia lized different
countries where the natives were darker
skin than them on the basis of the curse
of ham tell us dr. Brown now how should
people approach this subject with your
experience even though someone might
left their child with what they presumed
to be a righteous individual another
child gets molested you have an
individual who took their whole life
savings and they invested into this
fairytale dust and now you know what
they're really distraught they don't
know how to approach it the matter
because they've been let down should
they give up even though you have all
these crazy things out there being
attributed to the religion of the
creator of the heavens and earth that's
you know that's really the crux of the
matter and the fact that is of course
they shouldn't give up but I think what
you see that a lot of people do do is
they kind of retract into their own
private beliefs a lot of people had
enough experience getting sort of you
know hurt either physically or
emotionally okay the number of people
who were actually physically abused by a
man of religion are fairly few but the
number of people who have been
emotionally
who have found that in the end the
religion did not give them what they
needed found that over time they they
gave away a lot of their money they gave
away a lot of their effort a lot of
their you know a lot of their time and
they took a great deal from their life
but in the end they didn't get what they
expected from the religion they ended up
feeling used feeling deceived that
number is fairly large let's take a
break there we're going to continue on
with dr. Lawrence Brown here in addy
show I just want to say very simple
message is the main teen one of the
beautiful things about our religion of
Islam is the emphasis on direct ritual
and prayer who've gone directly there is
no intermediary the lights will go on
after the party and the party will end
it's very simple and very clear there
are no superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out and
you might not make it till tomorrow and
this is something that we need to think
about
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Lawrence Brown it's always exciting to
have you here in the studio and we're
talking about religion now before we
continue on you know people tuned in are
not yet Muslim neighbors and brothers in
humanity they tune in to the D show
because they want to see what these
Muslims all about so we know in Islam
there are any strange incantations no
superstitions we don't sell fairy dust
we don't want the people's money we just
want people to really reflect what's the
purpose of life why you why have you
been created and used the logic and
reasoning that God gave you and ask God
directly direct dial up for guidance
it's very simple guys not a man or a
woman he didn't walk the earth you
couldn't take his picture he didn't have
a zip code he's the one who created all
things but he's not what he created it's
very simple it's very rational so now
tell us and your experiences with these
people who again they are what you said
emotionally distraught what advice do
you have for them how can they get past
this and look past is to continue their
quest for the purpose of life and why
they're here on this earth right well
you know here is what I think happens a
lot of people they become so
disappointed in religious institutions
they become so disillusioned that they
basically retract into their own private
beliefs they go back to just saying well
I believe in God I believe in being a
good person I believe in the Golden Rule
and that's enough for me I tried this it
didn't work for me I tried that that
didn't work for me also and then I tried
everything in between or what whatever
this person has tried in their life it
didn't work out for them so they retract
into their own personal beliefs and that
suffices for them however many people
when they you know when they are exposed
to a religion that does not ask for
their money okay it does not try to play
tricks upon them and it does explain
what they have experienced up to this
point it does explain the disappointment
disappointments why were you
disappointed because
this why are there people misusing
religion because of that you know how
does misguidance fit into all of this it
has a role okay there is a there's a
reason why misguidance is there etc etc
when when you can make sense of this and
show how the core beliefs now the core
belief being belief in God belief that
God had sent messengers over time sent
revelation over time but that at the
same time with each stage and revelation
mankind corrupted it and it's the
corrupted revelation that there remains
in our hands in the Old Testament in the
New Testament and so on so that you can
you can read these books and and the the
books of the Bible will not be
completely satisfying because you will
find within them jarring passages
passages that are contradictory or that
teach things opposite to what we know to
be the fiscal reality if you can explain
all this explain how all of this
happened at how it leads to the
conclusion of the chain of Revelation
how it leads to a revelation that
completes God's revelation to mankind
and that does not have does not have
these disappointing fallacies then then
people oftentimes they will find this
very refreshing before we get to that
part that I really want you to elaborate
on tell us now for the person who says
you know what I do believe in God I'm a
good person I just don't believe in
follow it following any organized
religion you hear a lot of people saying
this sure how do you answer this you
know it's like living in a society
saying yeah I believe in America and I
believe that there are policemen out
there I just don't believe in following
the laws well you can't do that our Lord
is fair and just
the injustice is of this life will be
corrected in the afterlife in the
afterlife we are all going to stand for
judgment right now as I said our Lord is
fair and just to establish justice you
need a few things you need a judge right
yeah you need a court you need witnesses
and you need a book of laws right the
the court is going to be the day of
judgment the judge is going to be God
the witnesses are going to be the
elements of creation that have witnessed
everything that we have done whether it
is the angels that are observing us or
other people or even we will witness
against ourselves okay but in the end
the book of laws is what it's the book
of Revelation now that is what we're
going to be judged based upon if you
accepted it if you didn't accept it if
you did accept it how well did you
adhere to it and so on okay so you can
you can go ahead I mean it's fully
within your your rights to say it's
enough for me to believe in God and just
to be in you know just to follow in the
line of my personal belief so you can
you can choose that religion if you want
to but the question is not whether we
choose that religion but whether God
chose that religion for us if you
believe in God is one God you have to
believe that there is only one religion
of truth one if there's one God he's not
going to write two laws not all Rome's
don't lead to Rome you know I mean it's
just I mean it's just pretty obvious
right i mean you never open up a box in
which you've just bought a TV and find
two different instruction manuals right
yes I mean you never get pulled over for
a ticket by a policeman and he says well
lets you know which law do you want to
follow here the one that says speed
limit 55 Dylan other one that says speed
limit of 60 s 1 long it's always one
okay there's always one law our Creator
is the creator of the heavens and the
earth right and he has written one as he
is one he has written one law for
mankind now that law may have changed
over time I mean before Moses people
could have eaten pigs and after Moses
the law came down not to eat pigs in the
time of lot incest might have been
permissible afterwards it was forbidden
you know I mean there there there are
issues like this which are touchy but
you can understand how they changed over
time okay but the but the bottom line is
in the same in the same way that the
laws in our society evolve when I was
child the speed limit was not 55 it was
a lot higher I can't remember but i
think it was he in 75 in some states yes
okay so laws changed with time and in
the same way God adjusted the laws
according to the capacity of mankind and
the needs of mankind and the needs for
to hold the society together but the
bottom line is not where whether you
like the laws but rather whether God
constructed those laws and whether you
were following what he has bitten
mankind to do we know def is a reality
people don't like talking about it some
people might tune off right now but you
know they love I'm sure what you're
having to say so they're going to God
willing continue to tune until we finish
this show but why is it so so important
to discuss these matters and to have a
earnest desire to want to know the truth
rather than just continuing to work from
friday to friday from paycheck to
paycheck from nightclub tonight club
living that life and then you hit the
grave and it's too late yeah saying i'll
figure it out then is it too late to
figure it out then or you need to figure
it out now when you die it's over when
you die you're a book of Deeds it closes
that's it and what you have put forward
to the afterlife is what you have put
forward in this life I I remember one
guy just telling me well if I get to the
day of judgment and I find out that I
was wrong I'll just look God in the eye
and say I'm sorry well
you know if it is acceptable for mankind
to apologize in the hereafter if that is
sufficient for salvation what's the
purpose of hell what is hell therefore I
mean it doesn't matter if if you're
talking about Hitler or Stalin or
anybody who has perpetuated do the
greatest atrocities in the history of
mankind they're all going to say I'm
sorry but the question is whether that's
going to be accepted okay and and what
we are what we're told by God himself
what we're told by by revelation is that
no we are going to be judged based upon
our faith and upon our deeds in that
book comes to a close when we die it's
finished that's it got your shot right
now this is a sign itself your wife your
watch and listen is it making sense
we're not talking mumbo jumbo we're
talking about thing that it just makes
good old common sense think of this life
as a test yes and at the conclusion of
the test the test book closes you can't
go up to the teacher after the test
period test period and say you know I'm
sorry but I need to change something
inside that test booklet no it's done
you had your time to study and that book
that test booklet is the period of our
lives and when it closes the test is
over based upon what you did in that
test you're going to earn your grade and
your grade is going to land you at
whatever appropriate level of paradise
or at whatever appropriate level of
hellfire may God protect us from the
Hellfire we'll be right back with more
here on the Dean show
Walter say to me why have you become a
Muslim no I give a very frivolous on
should i say i want to be on the side of
the angels [ __ ] is a gar she's a number
one rap artists in the world he's sold
over 60 million records were a million
Steve Miller he was a young guy we're
basically everything that somebody you
would think that life is all about he
had everything you can imagine
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand back here on the D show with dr.
Lawrence Brown and we're continuing on a
very very important topic and people can
tune in every week this is what we love
talking about it makes good old common
sense some people now they just have a
hard time letting go they know that this
Trinity doesn't make sense they know
that worshipping an idol doesn't make
sense something in their very nature
their inclination something deep down
and their very Souls they know it
doesn't make sense what these Muslims
are saying that there's only one God you
don't divide them like a pie you give
all acts of worship to the one God was
unseen he's not a man or woman but he's
the creator of man and woman that's the
God retama the same God that Jesus Moses
and all the msgs god they worshipped as
God we worship that one God no
intermediaries no one between us and him
but they cannot let go of what their
forefathers did my
great-great-grandfather he passes down
to us and they just have a hard time
letting go even though they know that
it's not the truth what advice do you
give for them let go no look you know a
lot of people a lot of people learn
about Islam as the last religion they
ever learn about and yet when they do
learn about it they say huh wait a
minute I mean here's a religion that is
teaching that God is one that all of the
prophets including Jesus Christ were men
and profits that they bore revelation of
mankind but that that revelation became
corrupted right and it's the different
avenues of corruption that have led to
the way that religion is manipulated in
this day okay but at the same time there
was a seed of truth in all revelation
and the truth was what I have just said
the oneness of God the the laws that he
is conveying to mankind and that for us
to achieve salvation we have to follow
those laws but as you said many people
are afraid to let go of what they're
holding on to because they fear that by
letting go go of it they will be left
without a backup so to speak they won't
know where to go next kind of like a
backup parachute when you're jumping out
of a plane yeah now okay this is like
the story that I we were talking about
actually earlier today and just for for
the viewers this story was about a an
acquaintance of mine who was on a
parachute jump he had he had a monitor
by which he could hear the jumpmaster
because you know it's very noisy so you
have to have an ear monitor when he
jumped and popped his parachute he
didn't feel that jolt that you expect
right yes yes and at the same time that
he looked up he looked up to see that
his parachute was spiraling right it did
not open and at the same time he hear
the jump he heard the jumpmaster saying
oh my God he's dead he's dead he's dead
because he's plummeting towards the
Earth and his parachute didn't didn't
open and he said that at that moment you
know the the right thing to do is to pop
your d-rings and release that parachute
and then open your back up he said that
at that moment that was the hardest
thing to do because because you're just
you're just hoping and praying it opens
it open as it opens and you know that if
you let it go if you let that parish you
go and your backup doesn't work then
that's it for you but he said that he
summoned the strength he let go the the
parachute he popped popped his back up
it opened and he's alive to talk about
it today but the thing he said about
that is that there have been a lot of
people found dead on the ground without
deploying their backup and they went to
the ground hoping and praying open open
open open open and all the way to the
ground until they hit and that's that's
how a lot of people are with religion
they're not willing to let go of
something they know is not working for
them they know it's not working for them
but they keep hope
that somehow it will come through for
them until the end then it's too late
forget about it that it's too late now
people want to get a hold of you they
like you you are an atheist you're
trying hard to be a Christian and now
they can relate to you they want to talk
to you about atheism they want to talk
to you about some of your books you got
a few seconds please tell them how they
can reach you please visit my website
level truth calm or eight scroll calm
these these are both these are both web
sites relating to my books my articles
my works how I came to Islam and as I
said you'll find a lot of my writings
there click on the contact us about man
it will come to me directly thank you
very much may god almighty the Creator
Allah reward you for being with us thank
you thank you and thank you for turning
into another episode of the Dean she'll
come back every week we're here same
time same Channel and just let it go if
it doesn't make sense let it go move on
to what makes sense we're not going to
force this beautiful way of life on you
but just reflect if this made sense that
you worship none other but the one God
the creator of all that exists if you
can dig that you could definitely dig
the rest of this LOM which simply means
to acquire peace by submitting to the
owner peace the one God will see you
next time here on the D show until then
peace be unto you you have to praise as
if everything depends on a lot it does
but you must work everything depends on
you that's my point you see on the same
and I don't like that I don't like us
sitting here what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
do you wait for all these people to come
to this club what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come to
logon bring these people lost upon the
water put in our hand the ability to do
it now do your job
Oh